في شمال غربيه سوريا حذرت الدفاع المدني
السوريه العام في مناطق المعارضه مما وصفه
بكارثه حقيقيه جراء تفشي مرض الكوليرا
بسبب الدمار الكبير في البنيه التحتيه
وشبكات المياه والصرف الصحي شمال غربي
البلاد كما افاد الدفاع المدني بان العديد
من المباني السكنيه والمدارس باتت تشكل
خطرا على المدنيين بسبب تصدعها جراء
الزلزال والهزات الارتداديه التي ضربت
المنطقه خلال الفتره الماضيه
وفي الاثناء افادت وحده تنسيق الدعم
التابعه للائتلاف
الائتلاف الوطني السوري المعارض بان نحو
21 الف لاجئ سوري عادوا الى سوريا قادمين
من تركيا وذلك منذ السادس من الشهر الجاري
واوضحت في تقرير لها ان القسم الاكبر من
العائدين غادروا الى سوريا بسبب تردي
اوضاعهم المعيشيه وغلاء قيمه ايجار
المنازل وانقطاع مصادر رزقهم في تركيا عقب
زلزال